Okay, now what was I going to do? Oh. Sorry, I think we have a little problem.
What's the better one? Processing.
Hey, can a person get time to process a code?
I'm just putting these on the trick here.
Jessie and James are off the job. Did you hear anything about them?
What about Jessie trying to get to save Jeff?
Pikachu from this girl.
What was her name?
What's her last name?
Well, she's not a superhero anymore.
See ya.
Oh, excuse me, miss. I think this is how you work.
Down that button to process it until the end.
Processing code.
Process not complete.
Processing.
Access denied in ten seconds.
Ten.
You're supposed to process it, not make more.
Processing. Processing. Processing done.
Access denied.
Do you know what denied means?
It means you cannot get in.
Try a different code.
I think I'll do this.
It's supposed to be rocket.
Rocket rules.
The code is done when that thing gets to the bottom.
That bar at the bottom.
Down for it to process.
Processing code.
On this.
Keep processing it until it gets to this.
When that gets up to here.
Access is breaking out.
You must enter through this door.
Thank you.
Strange.
Double-bladed laser disc.
Rolling pinwheel.
Here's an apple.
Pop it.
Take your naps out there.
Go shoot.
So yours, Pikachu.
No.
Okay, what?
Are you kicked to bed?
Come on, give it to me now.
Pikachu, are you suffocating?
This is yours.
Bedtime.
Hey, you.
Quiet.
Come on, let's go out.
Are you leaving or what?
Come on, let's go.
We gotta give him some sleep.
Maybe you should get in the other room.
This room, guys.
Keep the bad guys out.
Come here, dicker.
He's cuddly.
It's gonna work.
We need a better lock.
Hang over there.
What black thing?
You know, that big old black thing.
Never mind.
And we are both set.
Guys.